[Musique]
joseph et rast bonjour bonjour monsieur
caruge bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique 1ère bonjour aux martiniquais
est plus particulier au moins au marigot
en tant que vice président à la
communauté d'agglomération du pays nord
et particulièrement en charge de l'eau
et de l'assainissement on va commencer
par cette charge qui vous incombent et
vous demandez à votre connaissance
quelle est la situation à grand rivière
on vous avez vu vous même vous vous
impliquez dans le règlement d'un
problème de l'alimentation en eau
courante il y avait eu une call est
debout en février dernier la en début
d'année qui avait gêné l'a fortement la
production de deux usines de
distribution d'eau potable et les
habitants de grand rivière on avait fait
les frais
quelle est la situation actuellement
alors la situation actuellement n'a pas
tellement évolué car il faut savoir que
le problème de gants hiver date de plus
d'une dizaine d'années et que suite à
des pluies importantes
on a eu un important glissement de
terrain bien on a vu sur le terrain
comment j'ai eu à intervenir plusieurs
fois le problème s'est réglé mais les
pluies ont recommencé
et comme nous l'avions dit on allait
toujours retrouver encore cette
situation elle ne pourra être réglé
définitivement je le dis bien et je pèse
mes mots que dans huit ou dix mois
pas avant puisque je le dis aujourd'hui
nous avons un cap nord avec notre
fermier smds part c'est comment tu n'es
ce pas des de tous les matériels et
aussi des infrastructures
tout cela a déjà été étudié tout cela a
déjà été décidé nous avons déjà passé
commande
mais nous sommes sur une île nous sommes
à la martinique à 7000 kilomètres de la
métropole
il faut bien que nous puissions attendre
n'est ce pas que le matériel soit
fabriqué pour ce qui concerne des pompes
et autres autres autres matériels mais
que les décisions sont prises
et d'ici une semaine je vais apporter
l'information à la population de jeu du
coup cette population il ya une menace
encore sur elle de 1 sur 2 si
l'alimentation à une menace même dans le
week-end là ils ont eu à subir des
coupures coupure puisque nous avons là
une usine qui n'est pas qui ne produit
pas assez d'eau pour cette population
des forages en était fait mais
malheureusement on a trouvé quelques
traces infimes de chlordécone
mais vous comprenez bien que on n'a pas
le droit ne serait ce que pour dépanner
ne serait ce que pour apporter des
réponses urgentes on n'a pas le droit de
passer outre la réglementation
donc c'est pourquoi nous sommes fermes
là dessus l'âge nous avons lancé des
études pour voir si effectivement ces
forages
on pourrait les utiliser en même temps
que les stations de traitement mais pour
le moment les réponses ne sont pas
satisfaisants je le dis souvent la
population de grand rivière m'appelle
parce que je leur avais donné mes
coordonnées et demandant qu'il puisse
m'appeler m'interpellait à n'importe
quel moment ce qui se fait je suis en
relation permanente et nous répondons
tout de suite aussi dès qu'il ya
problème c'est à dire nous à provisions
nous nous approvisionnons cette
population en eau potable au dos et puis
nous approvisionnons aussi en eau non
potable pour qu'ils puissent intervenir
sur leurs problèmes ménagers alors tout
ça on le rappelle parce que depuis le
1er janvier 2017 1 du coup depuis plus
d'un an maintenant la compétence eau et
assainissement des différentes communes
a été transféré à communauté
d'agglomération dont 4 nord à ce propos
histoire d'ô encore mais alors là
histoire d'eau trouble peut-être la
dette du 6 mhz
puisque vous avez hérité justement cap
nord d'une partie de du budget du 6 mai
pour ce qui concerne deux communes la
trinité et du robert
et alors il ya une dette des
fournisseurs enfin bref vous héritez
aussi d'un passif d'une dette
comment vous envisagez ça je crois que
vous voulez vous retournez peut-être
vers l'état
je veux pas dire contre l'état mais
presque aussi un petit peu c'est à dire
que le problème du cyclisme
c'est un problème très très très
important tant pour cap nau que pour
l'espace sud puisque à partir du moment
où la loi notre a été mise à exécution
c'est à dire que nous récupérions à cap
nord l'eau et l'assainissement ainsi que
pour les spas sud
il a fallu tout d'abord établi ce qu'on
appelle une clé de répartition puisque
cap nord ne prenait sur le sud dans la
dans la dans le secteur du cigm cap ne
récupérer que deux villes le robert et
trinité donc ce qui fait que nous dans
la clé de répartition cap nord a donc
18% temps des dettes est aussi tendue
passif que de l'actif 18% donc du
montant de la dette
de plus six donc vous dire que si
effectivement cap nore rencontrent des
problèmes voir le séisme qui a plus de
80% de ce passif alors il faut bien le
résorber joseph pasteur dispose c'est ce
que ça passera par une augmentation du
prix de l'eau eh bien ça nous l'avons
dit jamais que ce soit le président de
l'espace sud que ce soit le président de
cap nord monsieur monthieu insiste pour
que jamais jamais nous arrivions à une
augmentation du prix de l'eau donc il y
a des solutions
il faut fouiller il faut aussi trouver
des accords nous avons souvent des
réunions en préfecture avec les services
de l'état mais nous sommes en voie de
trouver les solutions
il y aura certainement des conséquences
il y aura certainement des gens qui
seront interpellé des gens qui seront
concernés par cette affaire nous y
allons doucement parce que nous ne
sommes pas là non plus pour faire une
chasse aux sorcières mais au stade des
avancées bon je ne peux pas publiquement
dénoncé un certain nombre de choses par
contre oui c'est vrai l'a6a phedra le
fait rage comme un jour parce que il met
en scène ses du service public ça
concerne peut-être les impôts mais j'ai
bien dit mon frère dans la foule on aura
des éléments très sûr parce que même au
niveau des services de l'état il y à des
insuffisances nous n'arrivons pas avoir
toutes les informations dont nous avons
besoin
donc il y à des documents qui ne sont
pas faits dans les règles de l'art il y
a plein de choses je ne veux pas trop
non plus dévoilé ce dossier qui est un
dossier très important et réversible les
est sensible mais je dis que l'état est
concerné et les collectivités et sont
concernés même aussi la cacem qui est
fortement impliqués dans ce problème du
sigle donc vous dire que c'est
d'importance et c'est pourquoi ça ne
peut pas être traité à la légère
très bien le 6 mai l'ancien rex syndicat
intercommunal du centre du coup ce pour
cela que vous le dites et du sud de la
martinique
allez rapidement joseph perez alors
histoire d'ô toujours et encore mais là
on va parler de l'eau envahit pollué par
les parlers les algues brunes les algues
sargasse beaucoup de communes sont
concernées dont la vôtre
le le marigot alors vous en êtes à
préconiser on a vu ça là cette année
après après qu'ils aient eu des
tentatives des expériences menées au
marigot injustement alors d'abord il ya
eu l'expérimentation d'un barrage
flottant
ça c'est en 2010 est je crois un barrage
flottant bon finalement bon vous êtes
aperçu que c'est pas tellement la
mi-2007 vous êtes plutôt réservés
et puis maintenant alors vous avez fait
un essai aussi de collecte des algues
avec un engin amphibie et qui perdent
une pompe ça c'était assez récent là en
début d'année
qui c'est concluant qu est ce que ça
donne pas ce que vous préconisez
maintenant que on a eu les ramasser au
large et vous dites là encore c'est les
moyens de l'état qui doivent permettre
de le faire
assis tout à fait de toute façon nous
avons des réunions assez souvent avec
les représentants de l'état en la
personne de monsieur le préfet on n'a
personne aussi des sous préfets temps de
marque du marin que de trinité et
jean-pierre moins bien on avance puisque
nous avons pu constater que maintenant
l'état accepté de débloquer trois
millions d'euros quand même pour
l'enlèvement de des sargasses et un
million d'euros pour les études parce
qu'en même temps il faut avancer pour
les études le marigot a tenté toutes
sortes d'écrit vous savez de vue le
dynamisme de cette ville nous avons été
pratiquement les premiers à faire les
essais barrages flottants c'est vrai pas
très efficace bon mais cela c'est pas
par rapport au produit lui-même mais
c'est surtout par rapport aux
dispositions physiques qui lie à
apprendre sur le terrain puisque c'est
un plan d'eau abriter mais petit plan
d'eau avec un accès pour les marins
pêcheurs alors que le barrage flottant
gênait pendant point.p empêcher donc les
les allées et venues des marins pêcheurs
et puis l'orientation qui était
souhaitée pour les sargasses n'a pas été
et
tout à fait respectée puisque un certain
moment on bien on avait une masse
importante de sa gas ce qui est abîmé un
peu le barrage flottant maintenant nous
préconisons le l'enlèvement au large ça
a été déjà moi ma volonté dès le début
je les signaler aux services de l'état
parce que je me dis on peut avoir des
bateaux qui au large réceptionne c'est
sargasses les traits tout de suite pour
les rendant un en bouillie ou en poudre
et oies jeté à la mer en point à la mer
et en rejettent dans la mer mais il faut
les moyens pour s'équiper de ces bateaux
là à mais la france devrait avoir les
moyens pour beaucoup cela puisqu'on a vu
que pour le nord de la france dans la
manche partout ils n'ont trouvé je pense
que et pour l'outre-mer on devra faire
pareil dernier mot émission touche à sa
fin l'église de marigot c'est pour quand
la division elle il ya une réflexion
pour fin août début septembre elle sera
réceptionné dans l'intégralité des
travaux tout sera fait c'est quand même
huit cent trente mille euros de travaux
merci je vous inspire assez d'avoir
participé à ce sens qu'a dit bonne
journée merci
[Musique]